This is an incredible story that broke this
weekend. We're leaked audio and video of a
private dinner with Donald Trump. Has exposed
that Donald Trump said that U S ambassador
to the Ukraine, Marie Evanovich should be
taken out as well as admitting that he is
afraid of Bernie Sanders electorally. These
are both huge stories. We're going to deal
with them one by one. Now, even the recording
is a big story. The recording is from a dinner
that included Lev Parness and Igor Fruman.
Those are the indicted henchmen of Donald
Trump's personal lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, who
Trump claimed not to know, and here we have
audio and video of a two hour dinner where
they had intimate conversation and it's explosive.
This is first of all, huge because Trump has
insisted time and again, he doesn't know the
guy, he doesn't know love partners. This is
secondly huge because all along we were led
to believe that Donald Trump wasn't involved
in trying to get ambassador Janowicz out of
the way that was ultimately admitted to by
Rudy Giuliani. He was trying to get Maria
Vonage out of the way. Trump had no idea he
wasn't involved, he wasn't calling for it,
and now here is audio of Donald Trump. Clearly
knowing exactly who she is that she needs
to be taken out. And then thirdly, this is
huge because every other day we have some
kind of release related to love Parness that
further incriminates and involves Donald Trump
and the people around him in the exact mobs
mobster like behavior that we have suspected
he was engaging in as president of the United
States. And it again tells us Lev Parness
must testify in the Senate impeachment trial.
Let's get right to the audio. Take a look.
Can you take over? The biggest problem there,
I think where we need to start is we got to
get rid of the ambassador is she's still left
over from the Clinton administration where
they invested or where Ukraine. And she's
basically walk around and telling everybody,
wait, he's going to get impeached. Just wait
like me. It's incredible. So one of the things
be, now that we have a secretary of state
[inaudible] interrupt and get her out. Take
her out. Okay, excellent. Do it. Awesome.
That's great. There
it is. I mean this is dead to rights. Trump
knows who you Ivana bitches and is calling
for her removal. There's a transcript of the
recording. Donald Trump's exact words appear
to be quote, get rid of her. Get her out tomorrow.
I don't care. Get her out tomorrow. Take her
out. Okay, do it. So this is a conversation
Trump is having with loved partners who he
claims not to know. He claims not to know
Lev Parness and as I said, um, he previously
has said, you know, I, I'm in pictures with
a million people just because there's a picture
of me with love Parness doesn't mean I know
the guy. And then we see, well, it's not just
with you. There's pictures of Parness with
Ivanka and Don jr and Eric Trump and Kellyanne
Conway and Pam Bondi and Jared Kushner and
Mike Pence. There's pictures with everybody
and here we have audio and video of Donald
Trump having a dinner with Lev Parness specifically
talking about the ambassador.
This has to be repeated. Trump claims he doesn't
know love Parness and that he wasn't trying
to take out. Maria Bonovitch here is a recording
of Trump telling Lev Parness at a private
dinner to take out Maria Vovvovich and speaking
to other people in the in the room as well.
Not necessarily telling Lev to do it, but
reacting to what love says by saying that
it should be done, so let's prepare for the
reactions that we expect from the right. These
are, these are the ones we've heard and are
going to continue to hear. Number one, the
release of the recording was illegal, wrong,
unethical, mean or, or really the problem
here, the fact that this even leaked. This
is a distraction. This is a political football.
Both sides use it. When someone likes the
content of a leak, they focus on the content.
When they don't like the contact content of
a leak, they say, Oh, how did we find this
out?
This was illegal. The recording's illegal.
This never should have been leaked that that's
just a political football. Number two, they
will say, listen, Trump gets to decide who
is the ambassador and he's deciding and the
recording saying, I want to remove an ambassador.
The way policy should be done by presidents
is not at dinners with henchmen like left
partners, right? Who work for Trump's personal
lawyer and who had the ambassador under physical
surveillance. Presidents get to decide ambassadors.
There's no doubt about it. They should do
it in proper venues. They should not do it
in front of people like left Parness and using
phrases like take her out. Unless you run
your administration like the mob, which is
exactly what Donald Trump does. Number three,
they will say, Oh, come on, love partners
is an indicted crook and we shouldn't listen
to anything love part. It says, what happened
to innocent until proven guilty.
All those people on the right who love to
say innocent until proven guilty love Parness
shouldn't be believed, and his, his recordings
shouldn't be believed because he's been been
indicted. Indictments are simply allegations,
right? But even more seriously, they worked
for Rudy Fruman and Parness did Trump hired
Rudy. It's not exactly inspiring confidence
in Trump's ability to hire the best people.
And once again, you see the Hypernormalization
a few days ago, Trump insisted he didn't know
life Parness. We now have a two hour recording
of them talking at a private dinner and the
reaction is sort of a muted, yeah, Trump's
a liar, you know? But anyway, I still support
him because he's doing the right stuff. This
has to be part of impeachment. Parness must
testify that as soon going to be debated by
the Senate in the impeachment trial, maybe
as soon as tomorrow or Wednesday. Let's now
move on to the Bernie story that relates to
the leaked audio, which
is just
as fascinating.